(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- I love it!
(Kelly laughing)
I love your running man.
- Oh my God.
That's the old school one.
- I love your running man.
- Right?
- Oh my God.
Yeah. We even got the
sprinkler in there with it.
- Oh yeah.
- We were nice.
Did you go out dancing
when you were like younger?
- Yeah, but I wasn't very good.
I wasn't very good.
- That meant you were fun.
- Huh?
- Well-
- [Kelly] That means that
you were fun, probably.
- Yeah, yeah. Because I wasn't ashamed.
(Kelly laughing)
- Just all out there on the dance floor.
- Yeah. I wasn't ashamed of how bad I was,
but, you know, it was fun.
Fortunately I found
something else to do, so.
- Oh, look, yeah.
You're all right at it.
- It came out okay.
- Thank you again for my birthday thing.
That was so cool.
- Absolutely!
Absolutely.
- That made my birthday.
That was really cool.
So wait, so were days from Halloween,
so do you get into it with your kids?
I love Halloween.
- Yeah.
Look, Halloween,
I think I rediscovered it
when I had kids, right.
Like it had kind of just become
this kind of annoying holiday,
and then all of a sudden I had kids,
and all of a sudden I
felt their excitement
of wanting to dress up and everything
and I think my son's
first one was a fireman.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Michael] Yeah. So he's
the fireman over there
with that glowing suit.
And I went so far as to
dress up as Spider-Man.
And I didn't know this,
but it enabled me to just be like normal.
- [Kelly] Because they can't see you.
- Nobody could see what I was-
- That's why I love Halloween.
- Right! And so kids thought
I was really Spider-Man,
which was interesting,
'cause they wanted to hit
me and stuff like that.
And so I was like, hey, hey.
- What?
Pew, pew, pew.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
(both laughing)
- You know what I mean?
It was what it was
but like, I was happy
because I was working
on a show at that time,
so I was actually in shape and
could stand in that position.
- And get up.
- And get up from that position
'cause it wasn't always that way.
- Yeah.
It happens to the best of us.
- Did you enjoy Halloween as a kid though?
- Yes.
- Like, I loved it.
I still as a grownup, even without kids,
I love a costume party.
I actually don't have time for a party,
unless it's dress up.
- Okay.
- I just think it's fun.
- 'Cause you really get
to see who people are.
- Yeah.
- Like why did you come as that?
- Yeah. I don't remember
any Halloween parties really
as a kid.
- Really?
- 'Cause I think it was like,
you did like parties at school
and then it was like trick or treating.
- [Kelly] That's right.
- But when I was a kid,
I was a different kind of person.
Like, I was one of those
kids who stole candy
from little kids and-
- Wait, what?
- Are you judging me?
Are you judging-
- Yes!
Wait, you're like the nicest guy ever.
- But where I grew up it happened to me.
So when I got older-
- Oh, it's like a right
of passage.
- It's a right of passage.
- Okay.
- You know what I mean?
Someone stole your candy-
- No, that's a really
nice justification. Yeah.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- That's beautiful. Yeah.
But everyone was doing it, y'all.
- Everyone was doing it.
It happened to me. So I kept this-
- People just walk up
and take your candy?
- Vicious cycle.
Yeah. It was like bigger kids.
This was like when "ET" was out.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- So it was different.
It was like someone said,
"Hey kid, give me your candy."
You were like this.
(Michael moaning)
- Yeah.
- And you give it to
them and then, you know,
'cause you didn't wanna get beat up,
and so you give it to them,
and then you just go get some more.
You go get some more.
So when you got older, you
said, "Yeah, go get some more.
You be all right. You be all right.
Go get some more."
- Oh my gosh.
- Yeah. Makes them tough.
- See, I'm sneaky
though, like as a parent,
so I can't really judge you
because I totally steal their
candy while they're sleeping.
(Kelly laughing)
They go to bed,
yeah, yeah,
and I'm like, I find my favorite things
and I'm like, "Yeah, that's mine."
And they won't remember. I'll be like,
"Oh, I don't know. I guess
you didn't get that."
- Yeah. No.
- I guess it didn't make it to the bag.
- I lie-
- Yeah.
- Or I act-
- As best as I can on Halloween night.
'Cause I'm like, "Okay kids, it's great.
You got your candy. This is wonderful.
Listen, you got a big
day tomorrow at school.
So we can't eat all of this candy now.
Just give it to me.
You guys go to bed and it'll
be here in the morning.
You can take little pieces
every day moving forward."
- That's what we do.
Yeah, that's what, or I do now. Yeah.
- Them cats go to sleep.
I sit on the couch-
- Yes! That's what I-
- I start combing through.
- You're like, "Ooh, I
haven't had a bit of honey
in a minute."
- I get all of the Reese's Cups-
- Yes!
- That I can.
- I love Reese's.
- And I like leave like
one or two in there,
in their basket,
so they don't feel like-
- They don't know.
- You know?
- Yeah.
- That they've been stolen.
- They're not that smart yet.
Yeah.
- So I put those in the freezer
and I hide them in a
special spot in the freezer.
- In the freezer?
- [Michael] Yeah. You don't
freeze your Reese's Cups?
- I have not. I freeze grapes.
I love frozen grapes.
- That's good.
Or frozen Ding Dongs.
- Yeah.
- I haven't done that in a
minute. Like since my twenties.
But like that's good.
- What about Oreos?
- See, Oreo is good anytime.
- Yeah, but frozen-
- Anytime. Like, warm, frozen-
- Frozen is insane.
- Do you do the chocolate
covered ones too?
- Yeah.
♪ Hey ♪
Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah. It feels good.
- Yeah.
No, it's just happy times.
Well, I heard that you liked Reese's,
so I thought I would bring you some.
I think Justin might have
some Reese's coming out.
- No!
- I think so.
- I think, yup.
(audience cheering)
Yup!
(Kelly honking)
(audience applauding)
- Oh my God!
- Thank you, Justin!
(audience applauding)
- Yeah!
(audience cheering)
Okay. Oh, that's nice.
That's nice.
Wait, here's my thing.
Let's be real though.
I'm gonna hand it to
y'all, Reese's, right now.
'Cause, see, this ratio, this is off.
This is not, you think
it's gonna be the same.
It's not.
You gotta go for, this
is not the right ratio.
I just wanted to pull this out
to help you out as a company.
- Yeah.
- It's not the right ratio.
It's not.
(audience cheering)
Take it from me.
(Michael laughing)
It's not, it's not as good.
I'm like, there's too much chocolate.
There's not enough peanut, whatever.
So, what can you tell us about the show?
- So, "Reasonable Doubt" is
this kind of interesting story
about this real life attorney.
And so, it's the story
of this woman named Jax,
who's, you know, she's married.
She's, what kind of attorney?
A defense attorney.
- Mm-hmm.
- And she's got like
her kids and everything.
And I'm like a blast from the past.
And so there's a bit of,
she's got this really big case,
and then I had some troubles
with the law and everything.
So, you know, it's kind of
about the choices that we have,
the choices that we make, excuse me,
and the cards that we are dealt.
- Mm-hmm.
- And everything that
stems from your childhood
and how that affects you,
you know, as an adult.
- Trauma. Yeah.
- Yeah.
And as somebody who's,
you know, older now,
married with kids, it really spoke to me
because I can relate to so
many of the themes that,
you know, persist in this one.
And the writing was, I mean,
Raamla Mohamed is the show
runner and creator of the show.
The way she wrote like marriage,
I was like, wow, this is very-
- She's been married.
- That's what I asked her
and she had not been married.
- What?
- I couldn't believe it.
- Oh.
- Watch.
- Now I really wanna watch.
- Exactly.
- And be like, you don't know
what you're talking about.
- Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
Yeah. It was kind of a
magical project in that way,
and Kerry Washington
produced with Larry Wilmore.
And, and like I said-
- Wow.
- It's something that
I'm really excited for.
Hulu's doing a great
job with us on this one.
And I think people will really love it-
- It sounds like a great-
- To be honest with you.
- Storytelling. I love that.
- [Michael] Yeah, it is. Yeah.
- Awesome.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- All right, well, speaking
of on camera connections,
I heard this story with you and Taraji,
and I really want you to
tell everybody about it.
Like it was in "Think Like a Man Too."
Yeah. I'm gonna ask you to say it.
It's like awesome.
You know, the only reason why I'm asking
is because I've literally had this moment,
not in the same way-
- Okay.
- But in like, oh no.
And like, yeah, yeah.
- Froze up?
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- So, okay.
So, Taraji, who I love immensely,
we're from the same hometown-
- [Kelly] So cool, yeah.
- One of the coolest
people you'll ever meet,
and most talented people you'll ever meet.
We're doing a scene in
"Think Like a Man Too."
And I had just had a kid,
so I didn't get a chance to
really like, you know, work out
and prepare for this role, and stuff.
So right before this scene,
where I'm like shirtless,
in the bed with her, and stuff like that,
I did about 250 pushups, right.
Not in a row.
- Oh my God!
I was like, you can do that
without being in shape?
- No. In like about 20, 25 minutes
while they're setting up the
shot and everything, right.
- [Kelly] Okay, just in a, okay.
- And like I said, I was
just working my ass off
to try and make this-
- Pump up the muscles!
Pump up the muscles!
- Pump up the muscles, you know,
make it look, get the blood flow going.
That's what everybody does.
That's a trick-
- A little glisten.
- That everybody does.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It makes you a little moist
and sweaty too.
- There you go,
a little glisten, yeah.
- Glistening. Yeah.
- We'll say glisten.
- Glisten. Glisten.
- Glisten's such a weird word.
- Moist is still different.
- Yeah.
- That's day time television.
- Little different.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna stick with glisten.
- Glisten. So I was glistening.
(Kelly laughing)
I was glistening and
I'm laying down with her
and we were like in between takes,
and she's kind of like in here,
'cause I'm like kind of on top of her,
and we're just sitting
there in between the tape.
Oh, damn. Right there.
There it is.
(Kelly laughing)
So, as she says to me, she goes,
"Hmm.
You kind of ripe."
(audience gasping)
- Which really translate
into "Man, you smell."
That's just kind.
- She was like, Michael
Ealy is not perfect.
(Kelly laughing)
And I was just like, I was like,
"I mean, Taraji, you saw me
doing the pushups? Come on."
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- "You know what I'm going through."
- She's like, cool. Reach for something.
- "I'm just telling you,
you know what I mean?"
I was like-
- That's a real friend.
- Towel!
(Kelly laughing)
- It was really hard to
be romantic after that.
- It would be so hard for me
to just not be like, whoo!
Like right their face. That's who I am.
- Come here, girl. Come here, girl.
Come here, girl.
- [Kelly] Bring it in.
- I should have did
that, but I didn't want-
- She'd have probably kicked your behind.
- [Michael] She would beat me.